[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of
dark season 3 on Netflix if you haven't
watched season 3 yet stop watching this
video and come back when you have is
full of spoilers so for me I recently
just watched season 1 of dark and season
2 back to back I finished it in one week
I absolutely fell in love with the show
I thought season 1 was amazing but
season 2 was even better and it was just
awesome how they could step up from such
a good season one to going to a season
two and what's interesting is the season
1 cliffhanger being that there in the
future worried you a bit but then it
still pulled it off in season 2 and
didn't fall on to that within season 2
it even a little bit of a more worrisome
cliffhanger with having Marta show up
with bangs and bring up another world
which can be dangerous territory in an
already complicated show with different
timelines and I are adding different
worlds so I had hesitation going into
the season but I knew they pulled it off
adding a crazy cliffhanger season 1 so
why not do it again
so after watching season 3 I have very
mixed feelings about this season I think
that it didn't become a trainwreck
because of the added world and they
didn't go crazy with it which was good
they kept it grounded they only really
added one other world being Marta's
world and then later at the end they had
the third thing of it being the world
that was the origin world but it didn't
focus so much on a different world
storyline which was great it was just a
piece of the puzzle here that I
appreciated
however this was the first season of
dark almost every other episode I really
dug and then the next one I kind of was
zoning out falling asleep a little bit
first time happened with this show and
that's disappointing in a sense because
of such a high bar it's raised and this
show is always going to be prepared to
lost and for many reasons and this
season kind of adds to that it's nowhere
near as bad as C's
six of lost that final season I'm not
comparing it to that in that sense I'm
saying it made some misstep set lost
also did where they add a new little
twist to the story to get to an ending
here and that was adding this other
world and my problem with that had the
same issue that lost how with the flash
sideways where you haven't seen launch
flash sideways was like showing you a
world that could have been of your
characters and here it's a different
world you're seeing the similar
characters from dark that you you've
grown to love and understand and attach
to but you're seeing them in a different
version so it's not technically the same
character and for me that takes me out a
little I don't think this kind of device
in storytelling in such good stories
ever helps I think it kind of hinders it
because then when you're seeing your
lick in Martha's world do you really
care what's going on with him I don't I
mean it's kind of there to show you to
serve the plot and that oh this is how
things would still stay the same but
they gave it so much screentime that you
kind of just was like okay like cool but
it wasn't the same gripping feeling you
had from the first two seasons and that
is my biggest complaint about this
season I felt less attachment to it it
felt a little more muted if that makes
sense
it kind of is just getting to its ending
that it's setting up from the top of the
season it really plays like half and
half like there's one movie going on
here in this season and the other half
is directly connected to the stories
you're attached to in season one and two
and that's what's really happening in
Jonas's world and I think that is where
it's shined
I think in particular episode 7 the
penultimate episode was the best I think
because it did that it showed you it
playing its strengths and connecting
everything you were invested in where
the finale went to that movie store that
I'm talking about with this other world
and then having Claudia show up and be
the thing that wraps us up by last
minute explaining the origin world thing
we really didn't see her to discover
that which was kind of strange and felt
a little easy for such a complicated
show like this and it was weird because
it was committed to that idea it
fanatically really worked that's what's
impressive about the torrid thing is how
they made
work with yonis and Marta and how they
come from this origin world but this
love story in it and the adamandeva
stuff all worked for me but in the
entertainment department this was the
least entertaining because of that
choice they made to add that other world
it took away from that feeling of the
edge of your seat the whole season where
there's bits of it and it's not all bad
it's mostly good this is still a great
show but to live up to season 2 it
really doesn't go there and I think it
just added its own little crutch here
because it was so focused on making sure
there's wraps up and what's tough is
they did wrap it up in a nice bow at the
end and then you add this kind of trophy
ending where you have Hanna
see Jonas's jacket and they leave it
kind of for you to decide like oh maybe
it didn't work they're playing with the
origin world and it keeps going then I
like make up your mind it kind of gives
you two separate endings here it almost
felt like an alternate ending just
thrown in there so I wasn't crazy about
that either it didn't feel like a
confident ending and I'm getting all my
quips out of the way cuz again don't
misjudge that I'm not crapping on the
show this is a brilliant show it's so
well done there's so much effort put in
just getting up the Banger first and
that also includes with the bangs here
right so Marta Katrina and Hannah all in
this world without Jonas have banks
that's another goofy thing like you can
use other effects to make them clearly
show their a different version of them I
mean Jesus Hannah was already pregnant
did she have to get bangs as well is
that just the quota in this new world I
thought that was kind of silly I like
they added to keep you kind of not
getting lost is a new transition where
it's always been that clock ticking
sandwich I love from seasons past but
they also added this like wormhole
effect when you're kind of shifting
worlds here I thought the worst episode
the season and maybe my least favorite
of the whole show was actually episode 4
titled origin because I don't like this
story they had where they introduced
yonas and Martha's child and this
character in three different ages it
looked cool but at the end of the day
when you look back and you finish the
season you're like what was really the
point of that it was kind of again a lot
to just serve the plot but nothing you
really were invested in and that's
because they introduced a lot of stuff
here in season 3 they kind of needed to
introduce too close this up and then
maybe I thought
maybe this didn't need one more season
because I always agree with keeping it
short to the point and don't let the
show die right don't stretch it out but
maybe they cut it too short and too
quick I think that maybe this would have
worked better into one more season
because if you set all this up in season
three then in season four you can get a
little more invested in this story with
his son and what Claudia is introducing
about the origin world because you're
you're shoving lots of us to really kind
of care about the end here so I think
dark season 3 had a lot of its magic
from the past seasons and that was kind
of in every episode like I'm saying but
it for the first time had episodes I
really didn't enjoy and that is
attributed to having this we'll say
flash sideways like lost or other worlds
with characters that are different
versions of our characters I also think
this show and season wanted to have like
an amazing track record with closing
montages in different episodes
especially with the music they choose
I'm always opening the Shazam app on my
phone to see what song's playing I've
discovered such great music from the
show I think the only episode that
pulled it off was episode 2
unfortunately which was the song broken
sleep by Agnes ole Belle but some of the
other endings with their montages the
music choices are a little questionable
kind of more poppy and contemporary
which I wasn't so crazy about I don't
think worked as well I thought episode 7
going back to that was out of this world
because it really did get really dark
and it had that Darth Vader origin story
to it with Jonas becoming Adam and
showing him in the episode trying to
kill himself and then kind of coming
full circle
seeing Adams story and I think Adam was
the most interesting part of this show
especially this season you always got
kind of chills when he came on-screen
and trying to figure out what he was up
to it was also cool to see Adam in his
mid age and then see Hannah I also think
that having Adam and getting introduced
to old Martha was really cool and it was
like a chess match they were playing
against each other the whole season but
having that chess match play again I
don't think it was clever just to have
kind of the fixer of all of being
Claudia she's always been a third wheel
here and to have the training wheel save
the day I don't know felt a little bit
like a cop-out themes that I loved I
loved how they really hammered on the
deja vu feeling and what deja vu can
kind of really
if it was something like this I thought
that was excellent and you don't know
did I see you before did I see you
different world different time I thought
that was cool
the shadowfiend they got going with the
light and the dark Adam Eva I thought
that was all great and you could see
there was so much thought out by these
writers from day one and where they
wouldn't get to but there just seemed
stories that didn't really get the full
payoff that maybe we wanted and I think
that has to go - Hannah - and you're liq
and just getting Katrina to see you're
like in the hospital I don't know like
it what does that really mean what does
that do it's so strange because it kind
of was like every storyline the first
season was moving at a good clip and it
was progressing and then this season was
like let's keep one storyline
progressing to our eventual end with
Marta and yonas because our how we're
ending this but let's kind of water down
everyone else's story and that's where I
think it needed a fourth season to
finish everyone's stories without it
kind of just being like Oh everyone gets
a couple closing scenes and that's
really it it's like wait so what was at
the end of the day Hannah's big purpose
why was she so evil like there's certain
things like that I wish was just a
little more explained I like the running
joke about the guy missing an eye and
missing an arm in the other world and
that you never know why I thought that
worked
teasing kind of people who need answers
for everything so I'm not expecting the
show to give me answers everything I'm
just expecting the show to kind of give
you satisfaction on everyone's storyline
which I think it did
clearly with Marta and Jonas but I don't
know about the rest and there was
moments where Elizabeth's story shined
here she had a big moment where she
killed the guy with the fire
extinguisher I thought that was awesome
another great episode but you kind of
leave her be after that I would have
liked more of her and kind of where she
contributes to the end of all this and
Magnus is still the worst character in
the show probably the only bad character
in the show
he's so hateable and he's always wrong
he doesn't get anything and now we just
see him in his emo version the black
hair and the tattoos the castings always
incredible I mean I don't know how they
get people to look so similar I know
some are relaxed really related but
Marta the old version was just pinpoint
even her mid age versions are excellent
so I mean this is a production design
team a casting Department and a score
with a composer that all deserve
recognition constantly there's probably
the best in the game right now at it
maybe just behind Trent Reznor in the
score category but still very close so
as a whole I think this season deserves
an eight point seven I still think it
was great I really enjoyed it it's one
of the better shows ever to be made I
think it would be top five for me only
behind shows like breaking bad leftovers
so it's not like this was a failure at
all this was a really good ending it's
hard to have a great final season it's
really the hardest thing in television
especially to have a good ending to such
a complication I think he did a pretty
good ending I don't think it was bad I
don't think this was lost sending where
it was just a horrible last season no
this was a good season I just think it
wasn't the best out of the three I think
you have to have a pecking order in its
own right with season one two and three
and I would go to one and then three on
the bottom there but overall I really
enjoyed it I'd give this show all its
seasons together a 9-point forge and
things really high and deserving of it I
enjoyed so much of the show I'm gonna
miss it because it was such a hit and it
was the first German Netflix show they
might do some kind of spin-off here and
think they could with maybe one
character and maybe it isn't even about
time travel it's just some kind of story
they can guide I delve into it maybe
some other type of sci-fi twist to it
we'll see because I think this team is
so good maybe they do a new story but
I'd love to see more from this creative
team it's so well done and still somehow
so underrated I think the best rating
and praised it finally gotten
recognition and deserve was rotten
tomatos had a pull with like the best
Netflix show and Dark One so that's huge
so people love it it's just more people
need to watch it like come on people
it's it's subtitles it's okay you can
read it look I can't stand the english
dub version and i think voice acting
like that is awful and not watchable
that way you miss a lot of the emotions
and things don't line up so just put
German audio on here and English
subtitles it's great and you're reading
composition will go up a little bit so
why not let me know if you throw this
down below I'd love to hear your
thoughts I read every comment try to
respond as many as I can please make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss one
of my reviews I do a bunch of TV shows
movies and celebrity interviews and
please follow me at Steve Varley one on
Twitter Instagram for more of me and
I'll see you next time